for all the billions of dollars and
years of work invested in making a movie
things sometimes go terribly wrong here
are some films that are out there
somewhere on a shelf that have never
been released
with a cast including Bill Murray Dan
Aykroyd and Zach gremlin's Galligan
1984's nothing lasts forever is the
strange brainchild of Saturday Night
Live Alum Tom Schiller who wrote and
directed the film and the show's
producer Lauren Michaels due to unknown
legal issues the film never made it to
either the big screen or home release
though it's played on German and Dutch
TV and was granted a single
unceremonious airing on Turner Classic
Movies
you will get everything you want in your
lifetime
only you won't get it in the way you
expect the film takes place in a
brazil-like surrealist world where the
Port Authority has actual authority over
all of New York underground hobos rule
the world and Bill Murray is the bus
driver who makes trips to the Moon try
to keep away from conceptual art
the whole thing seems too strange to
exist but a trailer lives on YouTube and
if you dig long enough you may be able
to find an unauthorized copy of the
whole thing
horror fans are serious about continuity
and the complicated mess of sequels
prequels and reboots released after Toby
hoopers The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
don't make it easy to follow in 1998 the
director's son William Hooper added his
own entry to the Canon with All-American
Massacre a 1970s set prequel to The
Texas Chainsaw Massacre 2 that has never
been publicly released the film's
biggest bonus is that it includes actor
Bill Mosley reprising the role of Chop
Chop Leatherface's deranged brother it
also promised to delve into the origin
story of the murderous Sawyer Family
years later William turned to
Kickstarter to complete post-production
but failed to secure the 8 000 funding
possibly due to the trailer that
accompanied The Campaign which struck
some fans as amateurish the film's
Facebook page has gone from intermittent
updates to silence so it's possible the
film will never see the light of day
meanwhile the franchise has migrated
from Studio to Studio with the latest
reboot Texas Chainsaw Massacre released
by Netflix in 2022
conceived in the tradition of terrible
1980s College frat movies spring break
83 features a cross-section of stars
from today and yesterday including a
pre-reacher Ellen Richardson Eric
Estrada John Goodman Morgan Fairchild
Joe pantiliano and even Lee Majors from
The Six Million Dollar Man the plot
centered around a group of four friends
who get their Revenge after being
bullied by the rest of their High School
graduating class unfortunately we'll
probably never know how they do it and
whether it's funny since production shut
down because they weren't paying anyone
after the plug was pulled additional
filming went forward a few months later
and director Mars Callahan told
followers that his cut was complete Big
Sky pictures now defunct website posted
dozens of production photos and even a
preview of the beginning of the film but
to date the film is stuck in limbo
in 2012 Tom Hooper the director of Les
Miserables did something that seemed new
by recording the film's entire musical
score live with the actor singing on set
and without any fancy Studio overdubs
even when they may have needed them but
Les Miserables wasn't the first film to
be produced this way take for example
2004's Temptation directed by Mark
Tarlov which we'll never get to see even
though it employed actual singers
Temptation featured an All-Star cast of
Broadway notables like Adam Pascal from
rent as well as future Avatar Star Trek
and Guardians of the Galaxy Star Zoe
Saldana the rock opera is reportedly a
musical interpretation of the Faust
Legend mixed with a murder mystery and a
sprinkling of surrealistic Animation the
film was only shown once at the 2004 New
York musical festival The Producers
claimed to want to finish the film
despite director Mark tarlov's death in
Dutch director Richard reports horror
film worst case scenario is about an
army of German zombies that rises from
the dead to exact revenge against
England over a devastating soccer loss
allegory maybe but whatever it's merits
it's unclear how much of the movie
actually exists filming began in 2004
but only a little footage has been seen
mostly in a couple of popular trailers
in fact the official promo was nominated
for a 2006 golden trailer award in some
zombie fans dubbed it the best trailer
they'd ever seen unfortunately it's
likely the trailers all will ever see of
the movie the production was canceled in
if there's a lesson to be learned from
Batgirl it might be that no property is
safe from the whims of Studios even a
proven multimedia franchise like Batman
Batman speaking
[Laughter]
Warner Brothers Discovery dropped 90
million dollars to bring back girl to
movie screens it was loaded with Talent
including Leslie Grace as Barbara Gordon
JK Simmons as her dad Commissioner James
Gordon Brendan Fraser as the villain
Firefly and Michael Keaton who reprized
his role as Batman with a Dilla larvae
and Bilal fala behind the camera it
seemed at least on paper that Batgirl
was headed for Blockbuster status but
something went wrong Warner Brothers
Discovery canceled plans to release the
film to theaters or even broadcasted on
Max the move was shocking given that
Batgirl was still in post-production at
the time of the decision no official
reason was given for the move though
industry experts have pointed to several
allegedly negative test screenings and
the potential tax write-off for wbd to
drop the expensive project there are
currently no plans to release Batgirl to
any platform
sorry Aaron Taylor-Johnson you aren't
the first live-action incarnation of
Craven the hunter an unnamed actor
played the formidable Spider-Man foe in
a 1974 fan film produced by students at
New York University the short titled
Spider-Man vs Craven the hunter was a 30
minute Color Film shot on 16 millimeters
by Bruce Cardozo who would later provide
visual effects for the Avengers and Thor
cardozo's film Drew on The Amazing
Spider-Man number 15 which kicked off
Craven's long run as a Spider-Man
adversary according to those who saw it
Craven was faithful to the tone and look
of Stan Lee and Steve ditko's comics and
even featured extensive visual effects
that allowed Joe Elliott Spider-Man to
crawl up buildings the finished product
was so good it earned a thumbs up from
Stan Lee and played at comic book
conventions for decades Craven won
Marvel support but not its Financial
backing or distribution rights as a
result the film languished in cardozo's
Personal Collection until his death in
2015. reportedly the only known copy of
the film was stored on credos's computer
which was destroyed around the time of
his death currently it exists only as a
handful of Scream shots
after several hits with low budget
martial arts films like Bloodsport 2
siblings and producing Partners Alan and
Diane meres set their sights on the
mainstream market they sunk 5 million
dollars into a gangster themed comedy
drama called the good life and hired a
cast of familiar faces including Dennis
Hopper Andrew Dice Clay Mom movie vets
Frank Vincent and Tony sirico and Frank
Stallone who also crowd his brother
Sylvester into a cameo but the film was
in trouble from the start and after only
15 days unions picketing the largely
non-union crew shut the film down the
production was moved from Miami Florida
to Ixtapa Mexico where things only got
worse Titanic which was filming nearby
ate up the local resources eventually
several members of the cast and crew
were fired and the water traps on a golf
course location were teeming with
crocodiles still the merezas finished
the good life and released a promo real
that prominently featured Sylvester
Stallone you want a dance you gotta pay
defense this displeased the action star
and his brother who filed back-to-back
lawsuits against the producers totaling
50 million dollars a settlement was
reached but the good life never saw a
theatrical release currently a brief 17
second clip is available to view on
YouTube
what happens when you bring together two
oscar-nominated actors a pair of
acclaimed Saturday Night Live writers
and a producer whose list of credits
includes everything from Fast Times at
Ridgemont High to Yellowstone the answer
is disaster that is if you're talking
about arrival live a 1990 comedy
starring Willem Dafoe and Joan Cusack
produced by artlinson and written by SNL
vets Michael O'Donoghue and Mitch Glazer
the film was intended as a vehicle for
Bill Murray who would have played a low
rent detective investigating a complex
scheme involving a Florida Native
American tribe what are you looking
forward well you know you want manners
you really do want you guys got to be
manners involved according to Glazer
Murray passed in part due to the film's
violent content one scene involved the
killer whale biting off its trainer's
head and Defoe took over his lead three
weeks after the start of production
Paramount pulled the plug on arrive
alive sources differ on the exact reason
but the studio allegedly wanted to
change the tone of O'Donoghue and Glazer
script by adding more slapstick elements
Defoe was reportedly uncomfortable with
a broader approach and left the
production leading to its cancellation
regardless of the reason arrive alive
exists today only in script form
although a YouTube video claims to
include three stills from the film
the thin line between passion project
and vanity film was underscored by
Chinese Real Estate Mogul Johnson when
he set to making the fantasy feature
empires of the deep conceived as the
start of an epic franchise like Star
Wars or the Lord of the Rings Jiang sunk
the equivalent of 130 million dollars
into the film which concerned a battle
between mermaid kingdoms and a demonic
warlord Jung used his Deep Pockets to
initially attach The Empire Strikes Back
director Irvin kirschner and Italian
actress Monica Bellucci piles of money
can buy talent but it can't make them
produce under impossible circumstances
language barriers dangerous conditions
and constant illogical script changes
dictated by Zhang caused several
directors and actors to quit the
production which was ultimately credited
to three separate filmmakers worst of
all a trailer was broadly mocked online
for its subbar special effects and
incomprehensible plot Empires failed to
find distribution despite costly
reshoots and a massive crowdfunding
campaign and remains unreleased though
Zhang insisted as latest 2016 that the
film was ready for distribution
hoping to rebound from a string of
costly flops like the late 90s film
Mercury Rising Bruce Willis signed on as
both star and producer of Broadway
brawler in 1997. the film intended as a
sports themed romantic comedy Allah
Jerry Maguire featured Mara Tierney as
the love interest to Willis's washed up
ice hockey champ and Oscar winner Lee
Grant as director the 28 million dollar
project had all the Hallmarks of a hit
until Willis pulled the plug after 20
days of filming Willis fired Grant
cinematographer William a fraker and
several others over dissatisfaction with
their work Dennis Dugan who directed
numerous Adam Sandler comedies was
brought on to replace Grant but lasted
just the day before the project was
abandoned 25 years later Broadway
brawler remains unfinished and unseen
though often cited as one of the
greatest filmmakers in Motion Picture
history Orson Welles frequently
struggled to complete his projects and
in many cases failed to even get them
off the ground his uncompromising
artistic Vision in Mercurial personality
led many financiers to withhold or pull
support for his work as a result Wells
left many unfinished projects after his
death in 1985. some like the other side
of the wind were completed by
collaborators While others like the Deep
remain uncompleted an adaptation of the
novel Dead Calm by Charles Williams
which was made into a film with Nicole
Kidman in 1989 the Deep starred Wells
Jean Moreau and Lawrence Harvey as ocean
voyagers Drawn Together by murder and
deception Wells directed the film on a
sailboat off the coast of Yugoslavia
between 1966 and 1969 but financial and
Technical problems prevented Wells from
completing production and the death of
Harvey in 1973 along with the loss of
the original negative torpedoed any
chance of salvaging the project other
than Clips included in the 1995
documentary Orson Welles One Man Band
the deep is gone unseen for more than
five decades
in the mid-1980s late night television
viewers in certain markets had their
senses assaulted by a commercial for
blood circus an ultra low budget feature
that appeared to mix professional
wrestling aliens Bargain Basement Gore
and a rock singer streaking about gold
jewelry the bill was a vanity project
from Cento Victor rigatuso a notorious
figure in the As Seen On TV Market who
created blood circus as a promotional
vehicle for a Santo gold jewelry line
the Santo gold heavyweight championship
wrestling belt is awarded to the winning
tag team in the new science fiction
space wrestling movie comedy blood
circus Santa gold was the subject of
numerous Federal cease and assist orders
for the outlandish claims made about the
jewelry which was essentially
gold-plated metal rigatuso reportedly
spent a fortune on blood circus but
failed to land a distributor for the
film reviews that called the picture
incomprehensible probably didn't help
still blood circus played for a week at
several theaters in Baltimore before
disappearing although Clips are
available on YouTube rigatuso who later
spent time in prison for mail fraud
charges continues to promote blood
circus through his ramshackle website
few animated features have had a streak
of bad luck like DreamWorks Me and My
Shadow the film began its convoluted
existence in 2010 as a comedic fantasy
tale about a human who discovers that
his shadow has a life of its own
conceived as a mix of traditional
hand-drawn animation in CGI Me and My
Shadow landed Josh Gad and Bill Hader to
voice its human and Shadow Heroes with
Kate Hudson as gad's love interest
initially slated for a 2013 release
Shadow was pushed to 2014 to make room
for the release of Mr Peabody and
Sherman when that film flopped the
troubles began
I don't want this one mommy he's
sarcastic Dreamworks Animation underwent
a massive restructuring that saw the
loss of 500 jobs and the cancellation of
several animated projects including
Shadow but the story didn't end there
Edgar Wright revived the project in 2015
and wrote three drafts of a new script
before Comcast bought DreamWorks and
ordered another round of restructuring
in a cinematic case of collateral damage
Shadow was canceled for the second and
final time approximately 12 minutes of
test animation and concept galleries are
all that remain of the movie
though its title suggests a sequel to
1999's 10 Things I Hate About You the
2012 romantic dramedy 10 Things I Hate
About Life was in fact a standalone film
made by some of the same creatives
responsible for the 1999 movie including
director Gil younger and producer Andrew
Lazar Evan Rachel Wood and Thomas
McDonnell were cast as the despondent
lead characters who find a reason to
live in each other and funding came in
part from a pair of independent
companies the uk-based in tandem films
and mad chance Productions filming began
in late 2012 but was halted in early
2013 when in tandem Chief Gary Smith
stepped down as the company faced
Financial losses however in
conversations with industry press
Smith's replacement Robert Mitchell
cited Evan Rachel Wood's pregnancy as
the reason for the shutdown and claim
production would resume in 2013. by 2014
the only active component of 10 Things I
Hate About Life was a lawsuit filed
against wood by in tandem for breach of
contract after she left the film before
completion Wood Fired back saying that
in tandem had failed to pay her the
standoff resulted in the demise of the
movie which exists today only as a
trailer and production photos a
30-minute segment screened for potential
investors at the American Film Market in
2013 for the years to have disappeared
Without a Trace though the original
screenplay surfaced online in 2022
an unlikely partnership between Jamie
Foxx and Ken Jeong resulted in not one
but two unreleased feature films Oscar
winner Fox and After Party 2 Star Zhang
announced an informal collaboration in
2012. that would involve each appearing
in a film that the other wrote Foxwoods
star in Junk's comedy after prom and
John would co-star and Fox's All-Star
Weekend jiang's film appears to have
vanished there's no information about it
after 2013. while all-star weekend was
completed in 2016 and slated for a 2018
release but the comedy which stars Fox
and Jeremy Piven as NBA obsessives was
shelved for the indefinite future
despite having a-listers like Robert
Downey Jr Eva Longoria and Benicio del
Toro in the cast it's possible that some
of the film's humor contributed to its
status coverage of the film noted that
Downey played quote a Mexican in the
film while Fox who played multiple
characters appeared as a quote white
racist cop when asked about weekend by
Cinema Blend fox said we're trying to
break open those sensitive Corners where
people go back to laughing again what
fox meant by sensitive core is unclear
but all-star weekend is in limbo for the
time being
Randy Quaid was still a beloved
oscar-nominated character actor in 1999.
when he teamed up with Michael Kane and
Catherine McCormick to star in the
debtors a comedy about individuals with
addiction issues the film had only a
handful of screenings which generated
such a Negative response that the
project was shelved the decision to pull
the Vlog on the debtors was reportedly
rooted in a conflict between Evie Quaid
and software billionaire Charles Simone
who invested more than 12 million
dollars into the project Don big bucks
chance wanted me to sit in for him
Simone was apparently displeased with
some of the film's content including a
fairly graphic sequence at a concert
featuring the German industrial band
Ramstein and won an injunction against
the quads that prevented them from
releasing the film The quaids Who had
invested more than 3 million dollars of
their own money in the debtors were
forced to declare bankruptcy marking the
beginning of years of personal and
professional downfalls though the
debtors has gone unseen since the
injunction the quaids attempted to make
the film available via the streaming
platform to cast more recently it was
listed on the Indian streaming service
binged which noted that the film is not
streaming in India
foreign